[Music]
hey Conan O'Brien here it's the
second-to-last webisode we're getting
pretty close to lunch the show on TBS
and I'm answering your questions and
today just to be a nice guy I'm gonna
answer two questions - I've never done
that before it's crazy the first ones
from Melissa Coco Lopez from Greenport
New York your question is how do you
feel about all the love you're getting
from your female fans I like it
second question Sandra Marquez from
Ontario California wants to know what
are you dressing up as for Halloween
Coco this is very interesting I don't
usually dress up on Halloween but this
year is different I'm not making this up
you can get these on the internet they
are now making Conan O'Brien masks they
are making rubber Halloween masks
without my permission I'd like to sue
their asses off but I can't find them
anyway Ted I here it is you can get
these online look at this this is real
here's my major complaint let's get in
close here look what's happening here I
look like a burn victim
I'm just is just horribly this is the
face of a 95 year old man this is a John
McCain mask that they repurposed and
slapped some Howdy Doody hair on and
they're selling it but I guess these
things are going like hotcakes all the
kids are wearing them and so I'm going
to wear this this Halloween this
Halloween Conan O'Brien is going is
Conan O'Brien and this is what its gonna
look like right here this is me and I'll
act like Conan string dance move and
it's gonna freak people out when I wear
this I'm gonna stir in a sequel to Point
Break wearing this all the bank robbers
is Harvey talk-show hosts anyway I think
it's gonna be great
ding dong person opens the door hi
thanks for the Snickers and then I do
this check it yeah
I really have man that's gonna be sad
anyway two questions price of one so
pretty cool I got to get back to work we
don't have much time left real show
coming up on TBS November 8th
check out more questions facebook.com
slash Team Coco ask me a question I'll
answer it
alright happy Halloween what do you
think
[Music]